how else is the moving stuff going are
you kind of getting settled in is it
dreading yeah it's uh because this is
it's a bit different now because i lived
in an apartment and this one's a house
and uh bougie i know
what the [ __ ] at this point i was
actually i was actually really lucky to
get this house because the previous
owner has gotten a job abroad and so he
was very desperate to find a tenant so
we got it at like a [ __ ] amazing
price because we were like when we were
looking for other places we were we we
didn't even know if we were going to
move because i remember talking to you
guys because you both were moving you
wanted bigger places and i'm like i'm
actually really happy with my place
this was a good size though yeah yeah
yeah it was a good size and i was just
like i'm only going to move if i can
find like a decent enough upgrade and we
saw other places which for the budget
that were set and nothing was really
like nothing really standing out i was
just like whatever maybe i'll just stay
for another year and then this was like
the last house
that uh we looked at because the estate
agent was like yeah we have we have one
more on offer um
that's uh that you might enjoy
yeah yeah we saved the best for last and
uh so we looked at this house and it was
like twice the size of any other place
they'd shown us for the same price yeah
and we're like what the [ __ ] um there is
there is a catch though which is i don't
know what the exact contract was called
but we only have it for a maximum of two
years so that was the cash
so after two years we have to get
ourselves switches if you're like get
really settled in you really like well
remember when we were looking for places
for the trash taste office that we one
of the places we were considering i
don't know if we talked about this on
camera but one of the places we were
considering was exactly the same like
yeah the first place we found it was
like this like three-story house that
was like oh yeah this is like looks like
a perfect space but then we found out
that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it was like
it was owned by an expat who was
overseas now but he was like i'm coming
back in two years so you better get the
[ __ ] out yeah oh yeah yeah i do think
this one's actually better in the end i
think the studio is definitely better
definitely better in the end but like
initially when we're looking at new
studios that was one that we were like
really happy with it was like good price
good location or what so in in the end
what what made you move there was just
because the like
the house
the location was amazing the house is
[ __ ] amazing um and i was just like i
i move on average every two years anyway
yeah so like i i'm i'm i
let's do it as we just discussed i'm not
one to settle down so i just i like
mixing it up you know yeah
i like getting changed yeah
and as annoying as it is like i do like
it but also like two years is a long
time if you think about it it is very
long so to me at least two years is like
a [ __ ] long time especially for
youtube something exciting about
upgrading a little bit as well you're
like you know i've been working hard i
just have a little bit of an upgrade you
know yeah give myself a pound on the
bottom i mean my new place is like three
times more expensive than my old one but
that's because i didn't know how i was
gonna
do financially when i moved here yeah
and i didn't wanna i didn't i mean yeah
when i first moved here i had [ __ ]
let's just
yeah same here because when i moved here
sydney just didn't have a career yet so
it was like it was i remember that yeah
yeah you're paying everything a lot of
it was on a lot of it was on me to like
well
she you know she obviously paid for it
as well but uh a lot of it
a lot of it was if it rested on you yeah
if like if sydney falls through and her
youtube career doesn't take off then all
of this is going to fall on me and
that's why i was like that's what i was
thinking about but now it's a lot more
comfortable we can both share the cost
so we were able to have like a bigger
budget but still not stupidly large
um and yeah we just found a nice pretty
nice house and then sydney's career took
off and we went stupidly lost
in my mind i was like because we were
living so far away would have to say
where we live now kind of like we allow
you so we
i don't wanna i don't wanna okay
um it was it was we didn't live in the
center it was very far away not very far
away it kind of was kind of wasn't i
also lived really far away from the
station so it felt like double damage
yeah yeah like for me i lived literally
three minutes away from this super close
so i was like five minutes
like i just had like a nice distance
yeah and then i lived like ridiculously
funny yeah
like i didn't you were like halfway
between two stations i remember
basically yeah yeah and so i had the
really annoying case of just like i'm 50
minute walk to one station 20 minutes to
the other yeah yeah which like doesn't
seem like a big deal but when you're
some days when you have to go back and
forth multiple times it really [ __ ]
felt dreadful yeah and i just got to the
point where i'm like okay i'm doing well
for myself i'm just going to spend the
extra money just to get somewhere that's
super close and that i can focus more on
work don't have to worry about traveling
like
now i don't have to worry too much about
and before i always had a plan precisely
when i was leaving the house yeah yeah
because i had to get i had to look what
the train was i had to make sure i was
getting the express train because where
we were was so far away that you could
get an express train that saved you
quite a significant amount of time
and so normally commutes are about an
hour for me yeah which is quite a long
time and you do have to really like
think okay why am i leaving the house
but now now i can just kind of be like i
generally know what time i need to leave
i kind of like the commute though
because like
me currently i'm also like
just like travel distance for me like to
the office for example is like pretty
much the same as it was right yeah right
it's not that much different time wise
it's just in a different i always
complained about it the most because for
me i definitely valued distance from
like where i was going
a lot like i really liked the commute
though for some reason because it puts
my mind off of work for eventually i
like it i
i liked it until a certain point because
commuting here was fine
commuting back is a [ __ ] nightmare
because like that's i would always dread
it right because commuting i don't mind
staying on the train but when it's like
when you're going back after we finish
filming trash taste
normally like in london it's like the
rush hour is from let's say five o'clock
till seven o'clock right where like the
the [ __ ] tube is packed you're not
getting a seat and you're like a sardine
for some reason the [ __ ] rush hour in
tokyo starts from like four to like 9 30
at night right no no it doesn't it
doesn't end it just it just goes it goes
until midnight yeah yeah so so like so
it's like the commute back was just like
a nightmare i would like dread it so i
would dread the community back every
time so it's it was just
normally if i was in london i would just
wait out the rush hour but in japan
there is no waiting out the rush hour
you just you just got to deal with it
yeah it depends right because like some
like you said you don't mind the commute
that's good i mean very op for you you
can get a much bigger place you have
even much bigger place than me uh
so it's it's kind of like i don't know i
just i hated commuting yeah and to me
i felt like i could spend my time better
and i did want to spend my time
differently like like streaming right
like an extra hour of streaming is a big
difference oh yeah yeah that would go
like a long way so yeah i think for me
as well it's because like uh an hour
commute for me now is so much better
than what i first had when i first moved
here because when i first moved here i
lived in a place that was a 25 minute
walk to the closest station yeah [ __ ]
that you know and it was like way out of
tokyo kind of thing so like you know
commuting into tokyo would be like an
hour and a half two hours which is the
walk don't get me wrong it's fine
walking is not the problem it's walking
in the summer
oh yeah sometimes you know you can't
always be what you'd like you sometimes
you have to carry a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
and that's where it really [ __ ] sucks
i'm so glad that finally i'm able to
[ __ ] wear a sweater right right yeah
it's so nice now like
speaking of weather though like where
did autumn go yeah it's just it just was
like here for two days and then it's
like all right see it just turned into
winter it's always like that i'm so glad
though because i can finally wear some
drip right
without dripping myself yeah
that's [ __ ] disgusting for like
the middle of september it was so gross
yeah i mean like i just like how japan
decided that it was going to be hot
until it wasn't one day and then it just
decided it was literally it it went from
25 to 14 in one day yeah and and it
doesn't look like it's going back how
does that happen
whether japan has four seasons everybody
that's what they tell you
no they don't it has pain for six months
and mild discomfort for two and then the
rest are okay i guess it's kind of cool